there's tremendous potential between our
country and Pakistan I think Pakistan's
going to help us out to extricate
ourselves we're like policemen we're not
fighting a war we wanted to fight a war
in Afghanistan and win it I could win
that war in a week I just don't want to
kill 10 million people does that make
sense to you I don't want to kill 10
million people
I have plans on Afghanistan that if I
wanted to win that war Afghanistan would
be wiped off the face of the earth it
would be Ghana it would be over in
literally in ten days and I don't want
to do that I don't want to go that route
so we're working with Pakistan and
others to extricate ourselves nor do we
want to be policemen because basically
what policemen right now and we're not
supposed to be policemen we've been
there we've been there for 19 years in
Afghanistan it's ridiculous
and I think Pakistan helps us with that
because we don't want to stay as
policemen but if we wanted to we could
win that well I have a plan that would
win that war in a very short period of
time you understand that better than
anybody we've been in they're not
fighting to win just fighting - they're
building
gas stations they're rebuilding schools
the United States we shouldn't be doing
that that's for them to do but what we
did and what our leadership got us into
is ridiculous but we will I think we'll
have some very good answers on
Afghanistan very quick